Christmas parties the Weekly Standard
details a new holiday party policy for
what a company could get get together
could soon look like if the Millennials
get ahold of the playbook the article
spotlights Vox media and how they
approach the holiday party since the
boom of sexual harassment accusations
across the country the biggest change is
receiving only two drink tickets for
attendees non-alcoholic drinks to follow
but is this over-the-top do we now need
chaperones and drink restrictions so we
don't have future incidents Greg in the
policy code of conduct for Vox media it
says be polite and friendly in all forms
of communication especially remote
communication where opportunities for
misunderstanding our greater use sarcasm
carefully oh my game tone is hard to
decipher online make judicious use of
emoji to aid in communication yes well
emojis do make things much easier
look office parties are overrated it's a
it's a forced kind of fun if you're the
guy or the girl who really looks forward
to an office party that means you need
to improve your social networks and and
and find people outside of work and if
I'm like you dude skip them like I do
because the point is office parties are
to get drunk at because it's free booze
you go to something where there's free
booze to get drunk at now because of
what the consequences and legitimate
consequences of what's been going on
people are worried you know and there's
no more booze why am I going right I
don't want to know no think about it
going I see what works sober I don't
need another two hours of talking to you
people I've had it after this show I go
home a two-drink limit would suit me
just fine the only reason I'm going is
because there's unlimited alcohol
because I won't be sober around someone
like that felt well you can't control
yourself I know I can't keep my hands
off them no listen I think here goes
first the Millennials I think they
changed it from Christmas party it's a
holiday party
now you can't drink it's not the
greatest generation and if you can't
trust your own employees not to sexually
harass each other after a few drinks and
all they're firing a bunch of animals
you're hiring the wrong people so I
I think it's ridiculous and I'm looking
forward to the fives Christmas mark I
won't be there see how interesting that
it's scheduled when I have to work this
date okay and we selected doing my show
which is wanted Saturday's it to avoid
you know legal problems I don't know
there's ways around this there's black
market for drink tickets exactly fine
yeah
blasting also there's people that don't
drink you go to the vegetarian kale
types they're probably not gonna drink
women yes you only have one drink anyway
that's right I mean this is that that's
just a good power to be careful exactly
I think you should be on the dance floor
more that's what I that's not just about
like vulnerable 'ti it's also you're on
the dance floor and then people you know
say hey you're dancing why are you
dancing so close with that woman I just
don't know well I didn't tell you to go
on the dance floor there is dancing at
our holiday party I thought that's
strange party a 5-1 or the one so far
well I can make that happen
oh the Fox one has we're gonna
definitely do that there's a who dances
at their holiday party I do if there's
drinks we're dancing yeah but you know
have some suggestions that just are
spraying water down the drinks they tell
the bartender's to water down the drinks
no mistletoe no dad no mistletoe that's
hilarious though right why would you
have missiles in Congress
it's just the most bizarre concept that
you suppose that stranger you can kiss a
stranger because there's something
hanging over your hand you know
something very strange happened to me
one time I have a mistletoe I was like
whoa we're gonna talk about in the
commercial break tell us everything
anybody Matt ley - a good friend of
several of us here at the table wrote
the piece never heard weekly standard